[Music]
good morning Hank and good morning
nerdfighters it's Friday January 4th
2008 Hank it's the start of a new year
and I would like to suggest a motto for
vlogbrothers o8 the vlogbrothers
just because we're less frequent doesn't
mean we'll be better hey today's video
comes to you in four parts part 1 the
new intro do you like it I hope you like
it you designed it but nerdfighters do
you like it let us know in comments part
2 the new website in 2008 nerd fighting
is going to become more and more
collaborative into that and we've built
a new site using Ning Ning is a fun word
to say nyng nyng nyng nyng nyng it's
like you get all the good parts of bling
only you don't have to spend money on
Jules
it's like sting but when he was still in
the police it's like cling only no one
ever broke up with me for being too Ning
II so anyway we built this new site
using Ning and now everybody can have
their own nerdfighter profile and they
can post nerdfighter pictures and they
can post nerdfighter videos and have
nerdfighter blogs and it's gonna be like
the kingdom of nerdfighteria so
everybody go look in the video info for
the new site then build a profile and
become my friend because Hank has more
friends than me and I'm sad part 3 the
political situation in Pakistan is very
bad Hank as I'm sure you already know
the former Prime Minister of Pakistan
benazir bhutto was recently assassinated
it's not yet clear who was responsible
for Bhutto's death but one thing is
clear Pakistan sucks a little more now
that she's died now I'm not saying that
benazir bhutto was a perfect person or a
perfect leader when she was Prime
Minister of Pakistan there was a lot of
corruption in the government all I'm
saying is that she was a charismatic
political presence and that she believed
in the democratic process which is more
than can be said for certain presidents
of Pakistan and yes I'm looking at you
pervez musharraf
that's right Hank Musharraf the
dictatorial President of Pakistan has
used Bhutto's death to delay
parliamentary elections that were
supposed to happen this month I mean
Hank to be completely Frank with you the
evidence is mounting that pervez
musharraf might be an asshat I mean look
at him Hank
look at that asshat of a mustache
actually it occurs to me that mustaches
on world leaders in the twentieth
century
generally a bad sign Stalin bad Hitler
bad Saddam Hussein
Kizer ville home ii the guy who gave us
such wars as world war one bad Genghis
Khan not a twentieth-century leader but
bad actually it occurs to me that his
anti-democratic as pervez musharraf
might be in the context of other
mustachio twentieth-century leaders he's
kind of a winner part for hank speaking
of the political situation in pakistan i
need to make an apology a few weeks ago
i made a video in which i ate a lot of
peeps while discussing the political
situation in pakistan and i accidentally
referred to President Musharraf as Prime
Minister Musharraf that was a
significant error and I apologized for
it but Hank I'm not the only person
who's recently been confused about the
political situation in Pakistan in two
separate recent interviews Hillary
Clinton said that Musharraf was a
candidate on the ballot in the elections
that just got delayed as it happens he's
not a candidate on the ballot in fact
tank unless I'm mistaken the people of
Pakistan have never had an opportunity
to vote for profess Musharraf because
he's never been a candidate for elected
office he of course took power in a
military coup and has kept power since
by being periodically re-upped
begrudging Lee by the National Assembly
by claiming that Musharraf is a direct
participant in the democratic process in
Pakistan Hillary Clinton went legitimacy
to his rule which is more or less the
same mistake that I made when I screwed
up and called him Prime Minister but
Hank there's a small difference between
myself and Hillary Clinton it's 3:10 in
the afternoon and I'm wearing my jammie
pants
whereas senator Clinton wants to be our
president not that we're endorsing
anybody nerdfighters I'm going to do a
question Tuesday next week so do me a
favor and leave your questions in the
comments section Hank
nerdfighters I'll see you next week